[Musique]
cocasse obama
mais comme on dit
your cat est ratée de huawei
les ide
eh ben non
ouais ya un gars qui vient d'appeler à
docteur cherche un chauffeur ça
t'intéresse je ne suis pas docteur en
médecine
je suis musicien je suis sur le point de
partir en tournée dans le sud profond
quel genre d'expérience avez-vous
et relations publiques verriez-vous un
inconvénient à travailler pour un noir
vaut dans le sud ça va causer des
problèmes premier mac tu m'écris c'est
promis départ ça sur barbosa n'est
jamais avalé de poulets frits de toute
mon existence dans les jambes ou adore
la poule est frais il avait une vision
de moi plutôt étriqué de donner un jeu
c'est soit mal
nous allons fréquenter les personnes les
plus riches du pays alors je pense que
vos manières gagnerait à être plus
raffinée mais pourquoi vous les briser
menu parce que vous valez mieux que ça
monsieur vallée longue à j'ai vu docteur
shirley jouer du piano
c'est un génie je crois aller manger un
bout je préfère ne pas mettre de gras
sur ma tenez où je veux pas mais de
grâce sur ma tenue
ce monsieur dit que je ne peux patiner
ici j'ai bien peur que non
[Musique]
comment il fait pour rester aussi
aimable il faut du courage pour changer
le coeur des gens est ce que vous faites
lettre je peux voir cher de l'aurès des
fois tu me rappelles la maison vous êtes
conscient que c'est lamentable sonné
note la distance qui nous sépare des
vastes mon âme tombé amoureux de toi a
été la chose la plus facile du monde
s embrassent le reste c'est comme
klaxonner à la fin de la septième de
chostakovitch et c'est bien parfaitement
bien de sortir des voitures
on ne gagne jamais grâce à la violence
pour ne gagne qu en gardant sa dignité
vous voyez c'est pas les vôtres vous
monsieur je me la pète qui fait les
concerts pour les rupins si je suis
passé noir est aussi passée blanc alors
je suis quoi dites le moi
le monde peut faire du beethoven
[Musique]
et votre musique ce que vous faites vous
et vous qui pouvez faire
que fait-on avec les restes ont fait ça
ramassez tony les écureuils le bourg ont
tout fait ramasser
[Musique]
alors comment tu vas je vais bien c'est
juste que je fais ce que je dois faire
et ça veut dire quoi
je m'excuse papa on n'a qu'à des jeunes
et discuter ça on peut le faire par vrai
s'il te plaît tu es certain que tu as
tout sous contrôle je sais pourquoi je
fais ça mais ça fait aucune différence
toi ça te dérange parce que là ce que tu
as créé de plus je sais pas depuis
personnage la création en oeuvre enfin
tam parce que je suis devenu qui es tu
devenu unique c'est moi papa c'est ce
que je suis ce n'est pas toi non je sais
que ce n'est pas toi qu'est ce que tu
fais un tu as toujours voulu tout
contrôlé depuis que je suis né laisse
moi
laisse moi te prendre une chambre à
l'hôtel quelques jours après tu vas pas
je voulais pas que ça se passe comme ça
mon fils a disparu nicolas chef sh&e f f
la personne à ce nom
il y a des moments où je le regarde
cet enfant que j'ai élevé cet enfant que
je croyais parfaitement connaître les
juniors king
je croyais qu'on était proche qu'on
était plus qu'un père et son avis
pourquoi je me sentais mieux que j'avais
jamais été alors j'ai continué c'est pas
nous ça ça nous ressemble pas
mon fils est quelque part dans la nature
et je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait je ne
sais même pas comment l'aider papa
c'est pas comme si j'étais malade c'est
pas un cancer c'est mon choix et je me
suis mis tout seul là temps j'ai joué je
ne peux pas y arriver tout seul
il faut que je trouve un moyen de
combler ce trou noir qui est en moi
j'ai encore une famille
je veux qu'ils soient fiers de moi
[Musique]
ce qui est en toi tu va le retrouver ça
va revenir
tu sais à quel point je t'aime
[Musique]
je t'aime plus que tout puisque tout
plus que tout
[Musique]
m
j'adore cette chanson
[Musique]
bienvenue dans mon vin sec
c'était une super soirée je te l'avais
dit que les mecs raffoler des show
déjanté vous regardez quoi le sait rien
elle envoie des textos un mec avis c'est
à moi de lui dire je veux seulement être
mieux classé avant pièce ça d'être dans
les cinq ans 1re j suis triste j'ai à
l'assistance bonjour que puis-je
pourrait bien je n'arrive plus à me
connecter et je pense que votre site
diffuse d'anciennes d'image ou alors
rien n'était pas possible nous n'avons
pas la capacité de faire ce genre de
chose qu'est ce que ça indique que c'est
en direct
oui madame ce n'est pas moi
la copie conforme de racheter ton qu'on
sait glauque équipe les imprévus sont
faits pour nous tester mais c'est quoi
j'ai vu assez chaud pour deviner qui va
choisir
mais je sais pas ce que c'est tu m'as
pris mon visage et je te promets que je
vais le récupérer tu m'as pris mon
visage
[Musique]
m
tu veux qu'on s'amuse un peu
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as là régulièrement
chaque or la police on appelle à la
vigilance de chacun
cheveux poils des aisselles et du pubis
les excréments la peau un truc d'odeurs
ce sont des trophées une seconde
monsieur le procureur venez voir ça on
reprend en étant dans la zone de
recherche
je veux tous les chiens disponible sur
le coup nous avons à faire un mètre de
l'emploi de la tuque pour le recherche
activement
c'est peut-être un des types avec qui
elle a couché elle était très très lié à
romanelli guerre et aux autres du
pensionnat vous allez faire leur truc
là-bas pour leur club secret leur club
secret des odeurs aussi on a essayé de
capturer les hautes herbes
on trouve des glandes aurifères dans les
tissus profonds des aisselles et des
parties génitales
en supposant qu'on extrait ces glandes
il serait possible d'obtenir un parfum
bien plus puissant qui combinait meurtre
pour vous
je les suspects tous même les naselli
gars c'est toi qui es tu quittes à rien
regarde moi
le mieux ce serait qu'on dise tout
un kit de la paix je reconnais ce texte
c'est l'histoire de grenouille un homme
qui a créé un parfum à partir du corps
des femmes qu'ils tuaient
qui rendait tout le monde amoureux celui
qu'il portait
de quoi avez-vous le plus peur
[Musique]
combien d'autres victimes vous comptez
faire